Sonia aquaramaju's parents thought
they'd be saving her life instead they
were committing a crime the senator his
wife and the Doctor Who helped them they
had trafficked a man to take his kidney
which the Senator's daughter needed in
Britain and other countries it's illegal
to buy blood and so exactly the same
process is the same set of rules apply
to organ transplants
the equator ahmadus found their donor
here in Lagos Nigeria a 21 year old
Market Trader they offered him seven
thousand pounds and a better life away
from here
modern slavery is hidden slavery I mean
gone are the days when when slaves are
put in boats and sent across the
Atlantic those days are gone but a
modern slavery
it's really human trafficking here is
the victim in August arriving distressed
at a police station in Surrey the plot
had failed
in court we finally heard his side of
the story unaware of the full extent of
the scam misled threatened the man
pictured here with Sonia said he was
warned if you do not do it here he would
carry me back to Nigeria and do it there
this has been a landmark case a legal
first of its kind here in the United
Kingdom the first time that anyone has
been convicted under the modern
slavery's Act of organ harvesting
and his wife Beatrice and Dr obina obeta
are due to be sentenced in May Sadia
Chaudhry Sky News at the old bayley in
London